un Grand Conseil européen est organisé
aujourd'hui dans la capitale
ukrainienne les 27 ministres européens
se sont donnés rendez-vous c'est une
première je vous propose d'écouter tout
de suite à ce propos Catherine Colonna
qui s'exprimait ce matin
notre présence aujourd'hui à Kiev et
tout d'abord un geste diplomatique
exceptionnel
les 27 ministres des Affaires étrangères
européens sont réunis aujourd'hui
ensemble pour la première fois et il
tiendront plusieurs réunions de travail
avec le président zellenski ça veut dire
que nous sommes aux côtés de l'Ukraine
je le redis c'est une première et nous
sommes aux côtés de l'Ukraine au sens
propre ici tous ensemble aujourd'hui
nous voulons lui témoigner par ce geste
notre soutien plein et entier et dans la
durée pour que l'Ukraine recouvre se
souveraineté son indépendance recouvre
son intégrité territoriale comme elle le
doit